I'm guessing this is jogging no memory
for you Nadia you've never had a
disaster in the kitchen like this knows
it disasters no one did one in
particular I was baking quite a lot and
it was during bake-off and my poor oven
was on overdrive anyway and it just was
making a funny noise at try to ignore it
and then I just kind of went down and it
was pastry week and I was making villa
Vance and the pastry was really delicate
it was finally working after that 12
goes and then the oven door blew off
just just boom out in time and you know
how when a kid is about to fall when
your child is about to fall you just go
to save it that's how I felt about my
pastry kind of lunched and I grabbed the
other door I was boiling hot oh so then
kind of it slid down my chocolate melted
skin and it was just kind of a bit
bloody and it was a bank holiday I'd
blown the head gasket on the car so I
was just sat there and i just i remember
just bleeding and very burnt and i just
said my pastry but then you won and it
was all fine away
[Applause]
[Music]
you